thank you
[Music]
and huge news
for a lot of people especially in the
Asian Community really the Supreme Court
has
turned over
affirmative action what adversities oh
it's only for universities well as a
higher as a practice for yeah for
bringing in students oh the universities
are over all the money feels 100 agents
yup yeah good luck
don't even know where affirmative action
is actually like
used us outside of universities like our
companies are like you know what I mean
like I don't know like hiring for yeah
corporations I've heard of it but I
always like heard of it in the context
of school admissions never like in in in
like Walmart has a quota or whatever I
don't know you know what's crazy though
is like when you look at the two sides
to this like communities that want it
and then ones that don't it feels so
weird it's it's really hard to what are
the two main sides because like if you
go to like Diet Prada or like one of
those like uh kind of like more liberal
Pages it feels like that's an attack on
black people a hundred percent and then
you go to like Asian side and they're
like cheering for it because they're
like great now I'm like kid who scored
higher than other races can now get into
the colleges I think it's so difficult
to create policy that can affect
millions of people because our lives are
so different for example right like I've
seen the positive effects of affirmative
action working in inner cities
because like let's say uh
you know you have a higher chance
growing up in a broke neighborhood to
get to a point where maybe you'll become
a doctor or something and then you'll go
back and service your communities and
stuff like that and even me I'm I'm kind
of a product of
I have all the recipes of failing and
then I got financial aid I got you know
all the second third fourth fifth sixth
chances to finally get a college degree
and then like you know change my life
around so like there's all these
I don't know it's kind of hard to say
we're like well you didn't get go to
Harvard with a 2.5 I didn't no so that's
like because that's more about that
that's true affirmative action working
like when uh I was in college and I was
trying to go to med school
and I would hear like we would I would
go to all these like kind of bridge
style programs do summer internships and
stuff at UCLA and as I went down the
line and asked like okay what did like
what does your package look like because
everyone has grades as uh MCAT uh
extracurriculars or whatever and then I
would hear a ton of Asians with like
super high GPA getting into middle tier
score uh schools and then I would see a
bunch of other ethnicities with even
like maybe even subpar get into some of
the top schools and then so I felt bad
just for the people that worked crazy
hard and they just straight up get
rejected and I'm like holy [__] and then
what does that teach like the kids all
the hard work doesn't pay off
I I I read this other thing too about
how it doesn't set up the inner city
kids for Success because like for
example right like they get passed
through the system and then when they
get to the top where you're in an Ivy
League or whatever and then the they're
not prepared to do the workload because
they're not used to it and then so the
failure rate is extremely high because
the dropout rate instead of being
prepped for that high level of like AP
classes and all that so once they get
into the classroom they're like what the
[__] dude I this is crazy I didn't I am
not ready for this level of like work
yeah training for ivy league is an
unnatural amount of prep like no normal
human being coincidentally ends up with
that much yeah five years old exactly
yeah and I think that's like the
lifestyle of prepping like Asian kids
prepping for high education you
sacrifice almost everything else yeah
your childhood pretty much I feel like
there was a time time when this was
probably a good like equalizer so for
example right let's say integration just
happened
and
um whatever you know because it was
segregated or whatever like the the
disparity in education was crazy and
maybe they had some like hardcore
um
like highly like academic achieving
groups within like uh the the black
community or whatever right but they
didn't have the opportunity but now
like they they have a chance to get into
the Ivy Leagues which was like a super
protected hardcore like
like you know
kind of like a boys club now they could
break through and I could now they could
come through whatever maybe maybe like I
don't know the 60s or whatever maybe it
did work then but I feel like it's been
such a long time from that point that
the original intention no longer applies
that could be a case too I think it's
dope if they put money into the areas
that need it
but don't lower the hoop for certain
people yeah like you know if you need to
if we need diversity then what do you
what do you say Lord of The Who
what do you mean what do you say lower
the hoop because some some so Asians are
recorded are required to dunk on like a
4.0 GPA hoop and then some other races
are like 3.0 or whatever why not why not
lower the tennis net yeah
yeah why not yeah lower the tennis
no yeah cause that's one of the uh
that's all bigger because I've also seen
kind of like an amorph philosophical
page the way they talk about it where
it's like um
where they say like
isn't it
by isn't it like a using the color of
their skin to admit students isn't that
innately racist that's that's that's
what they're saying yeah right yeah but
then there's people using that exact
same sentence in the opposite way yeah
that it is right that you're racist
exactly
part of this oh good the biggest winner
of affirmative action was white women
because being a woman you're a minority
and then if you come from a lower income
but you apply for everything you
actually win the most if you're lower
income I think but I think for just like
a regular white lady that's not like
[__] like Ruth from Ozarks
I don't know [__] about [__] yeah but
statistically they win the most
so part of what colleges are saying that
they're maybe gonna look at doing to
kind of just get around this is use the
essays part of admissions to like have
people basically talk about their
experiences and their lived experiences
so they can kind of discern yeah like
race maybe yeah because if they talk
about doing homework in the in their
parents restaurants they're like Asian
kid [__] stop don't don't bring them
in there you go and if they talk about
like growing up playing a lot of
basketball black kid all right I have a
bunch of kids just making up stories
yeah are you gonna have Asian kids
trying to like make them think that he
grew up like you know Hispanic or
whatever my uh thought I don't know if
this is correct so let me know please if
I'm [__] missing the mark but uh even
though it's viewed that like affirmative
action gives opportunities to black kids
or white kids to go to good colleges I
always thought that it got affirmative
action got manipulated by The Ivy
Leagues so that they cannot have all
Asians
I don't know if that's even remotely
close but oh where it's like so the
public views it as oh this helps
um underserved communities but from the
institutions from the institution side
let's keep these chinks out exactly and
that's that's honestly what I thought
because I don't think
any ivy league wants their image of
their student body to be all Indians and
Chinese guys yeah yeah that's also true
like the skulls and bolts or whatever
because again like hotels and [__]
looks like yeah yeah like like we were
saying the prep to achieve at that level
if we're just talking scores right if
it's just numbers yeah the prep they are
sacrificing their entire social life to
just have those exact scores so when
they don't get it they're like what the
[__] because if you did just go by
numbers and you didn't know what race
they are yeah obviously you're gonna get
shitload of Asians yeah like that's it's
not gonna be me that's why they they
started saying like well you gotta have
a well-rounded thing yeah and they want
that like socially like you don't do
anything else Asians you just like you
have no personality Asians you just
[__] math smart and that's why
there's that like there's that
likability Clause yeah have you seen
that in their admissions there's a
there's a likability trade yeah and it's
like a it's like a that's the hackable
trade it's like no it's objective yeah
and that could be based on your
community service it could be based on
things you've done extracurricularly you
do what keg stand for and I and I
totally get that like if they would want
a more diverse student body yeah they
are going to get some pretty great
Community leaders in there if you mix it
up you're not just going to get these
students that don't [__] talk to
anybody and they just want to do their
work the way they've been their robots
up to that point they're gonna stay
[__] robots and you probably don't
want a school like that I get it but
then also like admit it a little bit
yeah yeah you know what I mean like
don't lie don't lie that opens up a
portal to so many other questions
exactly so we can't have that but I
never saw um University or like
prestigious universities as a place of
Merit I always saw it as a place of
nepotism like you got old school
families that are connected it's like
Heritage it's like man we're all Yale
peoples you're gonna go to Yale too you
know like and they donate parents donate
they put tons of money in and then their
kids get in because of that and it's
really really a networking thing right
because it's like future CEOs future
whatever you're gonna go there you're
gonna rub shoulder to you though because
they admit like 10 000 or 20 000 people
a year like I just I'm thinking maybe
hundreds of people might have that yeah
but there's probably 10 000 people that
still probably try to get in through 70
white though the ones who are going in
through the endowments yeah it's 70
white but then some people say America
is 70 white ish so isn't that just a
thing that's what's crazy to me is that
when you think of the number of like
let's just do China just China when you
think of the people in China that look
at sending their kid abroad or like
growing up in America with that
education and having a goal of getting
into ivy league that's already a [__]
lot of them
and then you take into account Asian
American kids that are also on that same
track there's a shitload of those
otherwise we wouldn't have coupons that
are booming yeah you know what I mean
like that is a goal already for just
those in general there's not enough
spots for them but I thought well so I'm
a bit confused because all of these
universities I feel like they market so
hardcore to foreigners because they get
the most money from foreigners because
there's like a premium that they have to
pay right they have to pay a lot of
state or yeah but not only that they
also like bring money to the community
like they'll build luxury
um Apartments just for it being a China
tower for all the foreign kids that are
gonna pay five grand a month for these
luxury apartments right and on top of
that like it boosts the economy of the
area the real estate all that so like
I've seen so much more um I guess like
marketing going toward foreign students
and that's I've seen that outside of the
us as well like in the UK and in Canada
and all that
but doesn't that hurt reputationally to
have a ivy league College like the
visual image be like hella Asians
probably they don't want that yeah
because I don't think the ones that I've
seen aren't ivy league they're like UCS
they're like yeah yeah so like ivy
league is probably just that Heritage
brand it wouldn't be fascinating if like
we could do like a just for one year we
see who actually like got into college
like based on what they did just the
number just to see the numbers just to
see the statistics actually because when
I think of Ivy League I think of boat
shoes white kids from the East Coast
that like goes to the Hamptons during
the during summer with their friends and
I feel like they want to preserve that
and I think their way of doing that is
to be like oh no look now now
underprivileged kids can't don't have a
chance now and it's like you guys are
[__] shut up yeah for the Asians that
are getting the shortening of the stick
it trickles all the way down exactly so
like it's like regular like let's a kid
needs like an Asian kid from Arcadia or
whatever it needs Harvard grades to get
into UCLA and then needs UCLA grades to
get into to like UC Riverside right and
it's like it so there they have to like
crazy over treat over achieve like
almost be like [__] NASA genius just
to be like an accountant or something
exactly you know who's actually
benefiting the most though from the um
the affirmative act uh affirmative
actions in the black community or the
new uh African immigrants
because they're actually the number one
uh minority group that's getting into
Ivy Leagues they beat Asian oh wow
because they even need it because they
already come with like highly uh
academic minded I think because those
those groups they're trying to Target
inner cities not new immigrants yeah but
then they qualify because now they're
African American on paper so then
they're taking the place of inner city
black when it all gets filed and
separated yeah they're like yeah right
right right so it's not really helping
out like the poor communities and stuff
like that because you have Highly
Educated immigrants coming into the
states but then they're like hey we're
gonna qualify now under the black
category
versus like the the the inner city youth
who's probably working like super hard
to like try and get in or whatever and
then I think that's that's where it's
kind of like if it's just on Race yeah
then and you just need a quota per race
I think that's where people get screwed
yeah yay more problems we canceled